each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
kill my name is Victor she's right I I
did pick up a new role I I'm the
director of this new center that we are
starting in Mike's of research it's
relatively new it was announced on march
first and okay before this I used to
head up networking research at Microsoft
for many years and just you know just a
fact took on this new role because of
the growing importance of mobile and
cloud computing so today I'll talk a
little bit it's a little bit of a
different doc than the ones that are you
used to listening to hear I'm not going
to get too deep into sort of the social
software programming aspects although i
will give you some flavor of it but i
want to share with you a little bit of
some thoughts about you know one of the
small things we're doing in this new
center so you know when we think about
mobile computing you know this slide
everybody sort of knows by now and the
interesting thing about this light is
that yeah we have got lots of
limitations even though the phone is
very powerful wireless is not very good
and then batteries not very good but
this light could have been there 15
years ago and it would have held true
this light is here today and it's it's
true so the question is 15 years from
now there was you know Judith associate
this panel yesterday about 20 years from
now and i was thinkin hey you know 15
years from now would we still be saying
this but mobility still be sort of an
issue because it is true that wireless
is going to remain uncertain laws of
physics energy doesn't get better the
more you put back energy into a device
it becomes a bomb and and you know
computations on the phone are always
going to be less than what can you can
do somewhere else so so the question is
how do we deal with this situation
another thing that people don't need
usually talk
in the context of mobility is the
attention span and as you notice
individuals are we're doing we always
are doing context switching but we're
doing multiple things at the time when
we use the phone now what that means is
that this attention span is not being
getting changing at all over the other
over the course of many many years and
what we just do is we expect the system
to just do its thing right away when we
need the answer and so which means you
need to answer you need to do a lot of
things in the background to be for it to
be productive now there are many
technologies that we've been working on
not in the mobile space but in this sort
of the desktop and space and computing
press space that can be brought to bear
but we can't actually use them on the
phone today so what we have today even
though it's explosive and everybody
loves it but if you look at the apps
that are being delivered they're pretty
simple right they're not really really
computational intensive but as you get
more and more used to you're going to
want need more of those things and how
do we get there I talked about the
battery trans just to put in perspective
this is just a graph you know we sort of
just know generated just as a fun thing
and during the time when the battery
sort of what up this much CPU went up by
a factor of 246 X so it's and with there
is no set of real silver bullet out
there that that we can sort of say that
this is going to happen so now that
leads to the kinds of applications right
so we have you've seen a lot of videos
and you've seen well if you downloaded
YouTube you've seen things like
argumentative they're seen interactive
3d gaming all of this requires all the
three things that I talked about it
requires energy requires CPU and it
requires connectivity and so it's not
not necessary Z but we want to get there
right it's the story than the phone at
this point yeah so then you know it
becomes quite obvious that can we
combine sort of the the the phone which
is ubiquitously available to the the
infrastructure which is the cloud which
has got limitless possibilities now if
we do that then and if we do that really
well then potentially we could get there
so with what the vision is the vision in
just one line is to enable mobile
application developers to fully realize
the potential of a cloud and do so very
quickly reliably and easily now there
are three pieces of work a large pieces
of work we're doing actually there are
lot more than three but I just sort of
chose to do three and then even as I
wrote throughout this slide I thought
not even going to get to the third one
so we just focus on the first two and
I'll tell you a little bit about each so
first is the service composition which
judith was referring to as Hawaii the
other one is dynamic offloading of
computations so the service composition
work is actually a joint effort between
the azure team the microsoft research
and Windows Phone organization and it's
basically the idea was when we sort of
started this thing the idea was can we
you know integrate the cloud with the
phone and then if we do that can we sort
of try this out in universities with
with the next generation of programs and
see what happens so we went it off we
want to start it off by by creating an
infrastructure in the cloud that allow
you to program against it with the phone
and then we basically provided all the
software and get into that in a second
but and all the associated materials to
for universities to teach courses on
that on the subject and and so we you
know we are successful metrics or fairly
modest in some respect they were could
we sort of start to create new courses
around this area can we get new
applications out can you figure out what
are the services that you need inside
the cloud given you've tried this out
and then how many students can we get
trained in this new world so what is it
it is basically the way I sort of think
about the service composition toolbox or
you know service store or whatever is in
the following manner so if you take if
you look back many years and you think
about your favorite software package
let's take something that's not
Microsoft Adobe Photoshop we think about
our dough before the shop some people
got together there was a lot of work
going on in image processing right there
were things like red eye reduction
cropping scaling rotating all the other
good stuff and simply thought hey let's
look at these algorithms
put them together provide some sort of
an API provided a visual GUI on top of
it and then sell it and was a phenomenal
success but we're still sort of niche
right the idea here is that what if we
went back and we disaggregated all that
stuff took all the algorithms all the
different things the sophisticated stuff
that people do from different domains
and create them into service once we
create them into service let's provide a
composition framework which allows
people to pick any service they want and
put them together in any form they want
and that's all becomes your app for and
it works in the cloud but then we
provide the hooks in the in the phone so
you have sort of a in infrastructure to
use the cloud okay so so so basically
led to normal applications why do it
I've already sort of explain that and so
we did that we decided that we will
create this service store and we are the
list of some of the services that we
ended up providing the computation and
storage you already know about that's as
or for example the identification you
also know about thats Quintos ID
location and notification a part of
Windows Phone for example in then there
were other services now by the way when
we started this we were not actually
doing windows notification and round it
was alright would notification location
at that time we built it and eventually
the Windows Phone organization I started
to ship it as well but Rhonda moon real
a matchmaking speech to text translation
video cataloging OCR etc and you and you
can keep building these services you
know as time permits him as to so for
example the hello world application for
something like this could go like like
the falling this app I'm going to
actually show you a video of it in a
second I was built in less than three
hours most of the time was done in just
doing the sort of theme the gooey part
of it so you know here's a scenario
Spanish person goes to visit the u.s.
street signs are all in English wants to
convert it to Spanish how do you do it
right and so what's involved to build it
well you require an OCR service which
will take the text and and convert it
okay and then you need a translation
engine that's another service then from
a translation engine you also need a
speech synthesis engine
you're going to take and you're going to
speak it back and you might also need
all the identification on all the good
stuff so i don't know if i have a
there's a mic here so i'm going to just
use my okay
here we have a sample application of a
Hawaii services concept from Microsoft
Research what we have is an image
translation service that is running in
the cloud we submit picture of a
document or a road sign and then that
gets recognized to text and then
subsequently translate it to a language
of choice and then know like spoken back
to the user so presenting the correlated
output of the translator translator text
as well as the speech part of it is the
important part here so let me select a
picture now is get submitted to 2000 you
actually see the output right away let
us see this time runner with a doc
bigger document here we have various
passages let me select one from new york
times article support so you would take
a picture with any payment only know the
hero al-khawaja the portuguese nekid ave
chicago an Illinois Appellate Court a
monster tajima knew it wasn't roseville
also spoken back no classification Qatar
para el alcalde de chicago chase a
lecciones del mess prossimo porque le
abano sido de silly endo a la ciudad
durante bastante tiempo en aparecer en
la bolita electoral so y so that you
know you basically treo was you take a
picture send it to the cloud service and
you saw the speed with which it
translated the document and came back
now so we built lots of services like
that one service for example we built
was a relay service now here the idea
was if you want to communicate with
another phone how do you do that and you
want to sort of maybe you will talk to
somebody while you doing data
connectivity now generally it's not easy
because you don't know what the IP
addresses and so and then there's all
these issues like natural versal and you
know private eye peas and pursue public
eye peas etc so we built a service
called the rendezvous service which
allows you to sort of hook up with
whoever as many friends as you want and
then a relay service which will allow
you to to communicate now we put the
service out and then
you know the service was built in the
context of gaming which I'll tell you in
a second about but somebody in singapore
management university which was also
teaching a course around hawaii to
students went ahead and build this
particular app out of this hi this is
rajesh ballad assistant professor and
school of information systems at a
singapore management university i'm
presenting a demo application or
protecta why--yes relay service in this
application we have a video player that
synchronizes between two different
phones that are graphically dispersed
what we can see in this demo is the left
one is playing a video while the right
phone is waiting to because the left
phone is actually playing parts of the
video that right phone is already seen
when the left phone catches up you will
see that both phones start synchronizing
at the same time this allows people who
are geographically dispersed to be able
to see videos together in a shared
interactive manner you can also
exchanged text messages with each other
and they can also send audio chat to
each other we will now see that if you
look at the display down here you see
that the left phone is six seconds five
seconds behind the right one and they
have now caught up and both phones are
in sync and everything is streaming
through the relay service even though
the video is located somewhere on the
internet as I will show you now you can
even send voice messages to each other
this is a great video
and that concludes the demo of the relay
service demo application thank you so
this is exactly the point which is that
you know we build the services and put
them out there and then you start to see
people start to use it in very different
manner now here's another example of
another service we build which is the
matchmaking service the idea here is
that if you're into gaming then you know
and if you're into sort of internet
gaming you know that in order to play
games you want to be playing game with
somebody who who's going to have
sustained connectivity to you and in the
mobile world it becomes even harder to
do that because people are moving around
and wireless connectivity is not so good
so the idea is you create a matchmaking
service which will then look at the
Layton sees for example of the network
that people are connected to we'll look
at all the other different factors that
come into play and predict certain
things and so from that it will sort of
say to you if you want to play a game
will tell you these are the candidate
people that you can play a game against
and so you do you know whatever you need
to do and populate that list and then
people will play the game so now based
on that a couple of researchers build
the following thing so this is I don't
actually not a game of myself so I don't
know too much about it but there's a
game called light psyche cycles and the
way sir if it works is that you have to
move around this particular space and if
you move and hit some if you move to a
space with somebody else's head its
games over you've sort of lost it okay
last thing so this is the video of it
and i think the video will explain what
it is besides running around here i
don't know if it has audio and it not
but what they say i don't know if they
have audience I'll just speak so what
the researchers did is they actually
took the phone and connected it to a
head head up heads up display and so you
can see it and then they sort of walk
around in different places but you know
in order for it is to work it needs very
fine-grained localization it also needs
the relay services because the phones
are going to work with one another and
it needs sort of the match making things
so you can actually play the game with
it of course nobody plays the game
running around in this sort of fashion
but you know
they made this work so I thought I was
kind of cute okay so how do you build in
hawai up and here's a little plug for
for a friday afternoon session there's
actually going to be a little session
chaired by Judith here which is going to
talk about how you would actually build
build a Hawaii app and it's it's kind of
a fun thing because they work pretty
hard at this and they've shown that you
actually built a whole lap right in
front of you and then you have since you
have the phones you start to interact
with the you know with the instructor
and it's kind of cute it's it's actually
quite good so I you know I want to
mention how we started if so in spring
of 2010 I had to researchers visiting my
group from UCS and Duke and I was
brainstorming with them we thought hey
wouldn't it be fun to sort of teach
courses around it and they agreed to be
the guinea pigs we ended up teaching are
they ended up three universities ended
up teaching courses and speak 2010 it
was remarkably successful the
professor's godly reading reviews back
from the students and the students loved
it because it was in the hardest field
that they you can be in and they were
doing all these cool stuff so we kept up
with it and thanks to Judith who was
supporting all this effort and and
putting her own resources into all this
stuff this spring 2011 we had up to 20
University signed up and this was not
with that I mean this was without doing
much of evangelization and and you know
he would see some of the nose of the
universities and all the reports tell us
that this is turning out to be really
really fun for all of them and also fun
for all of us and gratifying for all of
us that is actually is something that
people are really gravitating towards
and it's working and then you know the
proof is in the pudding in terms of the
applications so we looked at you know
just there's a snapshot of a bunch of
applications that the students wrote and
these applications are a lot more
sophisticated than anything you get in
android or even iPhone or you get in you
know even windows phone for now because
they actually you know are done by
fairly smart people but also uses
services that you know are not usually
available to them so just to sort of
help people along along the way we also
given out support
44 sort of the best Awards in each
universities and the Imagine Cup is
going to have a session on mobile cloud
so it's been a fairly successful program
for us in there's some Facebook sessions
facebook community building stuff going
on now I was asked yesterday to sort of
announced this as well today so we did
roll out new SDK the new SDK has new
services in it for example speech to
text and now the big one is the optical
character recognition so now what I
showed you how you know anybody can just
implement it in whatever way you want
and this SDK is available for both the
client side and the server sighs you
download it and you can start
programming and all this stuff it's
downloaded from their website now so is
this enough is the question right and I
would say it's not enough and you
probably guessed why it is because here
are some facts right the facts are that
the usage is going up it's going out
tremendously power the amount of data
that everybody is consuming on a
wireless network is also going up
tremendously and in the demands of the
new applications are very very high now
we did some research to that will come
to in a second to sort of prove this is
all true but independent here's another
graph which sort of shows how the green
is where the data track or the voice
traffic is and the yellow or yellow bars
are the data traffic and you can see how
fast they are growing on this curve this
is from Cisco when it talks about what
kind of data is actually being used more
and more and you see the lot more video
being you being downloaded and in the
United States at least the FCC for
example has been warned by many suits
that you're running out of spectrum
which means that we can speculate we can
think about all these great things we
can do but if we don't have the
bandwidth remove any of the data back
and forth within the cloud in the phone
so we are we're not going to get screwed
in some sense we're not going to be able
to get this done so yeah here's here's
the the paper that i was talking about
that we did ourselves we build this
thing called the treaty test actually we
build it with the University of Michigan
and this graph is old it shows 56,000
users actually there's more than hundred
thousand users and what we determine
into
is network no matter what your cellular
providers say is there a certain amount
of throughput is maximum you can get and
it's not good so you can't do really
interesting things now for example this
is a little experiment that in my office
a while ago admittedly but nevertheless
it it shows you what the problem is so
if you if you take a phone use the Wi-Fi
connection and go to some some IP
address this one for example belong to
some Google Google server you get about
11 hops right you do the same thing or a
3g networks you get 25 hops the reason
is because it's not just the bandwidth
of the last hop and the wireless the
cellar infrastructure is is crud haven't
it's very badly like the theme for the
even the wired infrastructure of the
cellular providers is very poorly
constructed and you can start to see
that you're actually adding so many
routes to the system before you get to
the endpoint and that adds a lot more
latency than you can handle now latency
impacts energy here's a little graph
which sort of shows for example what is
the in this case on the vertical axis is
time when the horizontal is how much
data is received and you can see that as
and the three bars I show is if you're
going over the the top one is if you're
going over the 3g network the dead one
is going over Wi-Fi network and this is
a Maui which I'll explain in a second
which is the last one explain that sort
of a solution that we've been talking to
planning on doing and you can see sort
of you match this graph with this one
and you see that if the communication
cost is very large the energy cost is
very large too and the reason for that
is the radio stay up the radios and if
you turn them up and down even then you
lose because as soon as you turn radio
up use there's an energy spike and so
you can't really do that much and so if
we keep it up there's you know I'm just
waiting waiting for data to come you're
going to lose energy as well so that
drains your energy and that's a problem
as well so working with CMU and a couple
of other Institute we proposed this idea
of what we call cloudlets okay the idea
of cloudlets is something that is you
have the cloud right in a big large data
centers you have the cell phones and
things like
that and then you have an infrastructure
piece which we call the cloud 'let okay
and then basically it's a resource which
infrastructure computing device which
has very high speed internet to the
cloud on to the main cloud and it's as
close to the mobile device as possible
now I'll explain to you what I mean by
that now let's see if you were able to
build a device like that or have a
device like that around here then you
get better performance right this sort
of talks about it so that means the
behavior of the application is is good
there's very little latency available in
the system which which will be good for
energy as well harsh you have you know
extended computing horsepower and
another big thing is you're not using
the spectrum the licensed spectrum which
is very difficult to get you get so the
instantiation of cloudlets is the Maui
know this is the Microsoft version of it
so so the cloudlets concept if you hear
about it again it's sort of a jointly
developed thing between within us
Carnegie Mellon you know there was
somebody from IBM Research and somebody
from a TD research but but near Maui
sort of the instantiation of that so the
basic hardware capability is just a PC
really and and and it has very high
bandwidth connections to the Internet
and then software capabilities that we
are working on essentially it has to be
trusted with the NHC why in a second and
it should be a capable of handling Dooku
could be coded offloads okay so how do
you when we put something like a Maui
node well think about here you've got
wireless connectivity if you're using
wireless LANs you've got the way it
works is you've got access points here
behind the access points as a wireless
switch the access points are dumb the
wireless which is doing all the work
well you take a wireless switch and you
put them now we know to connect a pc to
it that's it you're done with the right
software you're done so now you don't
actually have to go anywhere you would
just sort of do a computation lava
flowed into that machine the research
questions then become for us is what do
you offload like so when you and you
when you're trying to use this you know
what parts of the applications you
offload and then how do you decide
whether it should be off
it or not there are certain instances
where offloading doesn't medicine sense
because there is a cost associated with
communications just as there's a cost
associated with batteries battery well
you know is used for computation and
communications and so you have to
balance this too as well if your
communication channel is not very good
you don't want to be doing this because
you're doing all these three
transmissions and then another one is
how do you do this without having the
program is think about all this stuff
right so in here everybody could do it
really easily but most of the world is
not built with pH not it's not PhDs and
they just write programs they want to
think about any of these issues that I'm
bringing up here and there so how do we
do it and that was sort of the key to
adoption which is the simple programming
model for for the application riders so
so then the strategy we adopted I don't
have as much time so I'm going to go
really fast on this and I apologize for
this but we have a paper that explains
all this stuff is basically we use a
semi-automatic approach to it and you
know the highest level the way it works
is you've got some code and what you do
is you you you add some annotations on
the on the code and you say it's
removable now don't worry about the fact
whether you got it right or got it wrong
just blink your sprinkle it in a way
that sort of that that program of thinks
is probably going to work with source
you've got self-contained codes and you
sort of add at this removable objects in
there or removable tags in there now if
you get it wrong no problems actually
the system will will work with it now
one of the advantages of something like
this as you will see is that the way the
way we sort of build the system was we
were pretty cognizant of the fact that
you may not have network connectivity
all the time so what happens then it
does the program start working and the
answer is no it doesn't start working it
actually you see a little bit of a
glitch for till it hits some sort of a
threshold and it decides it's not
working so it just continues to work on
the under on your machine itself so that
was one of the properties of those
things another question that might come
to you right away was why don't he do
this tactically why do you have to do it
dynamically the answer is that actually
that's actually not a good idea either
because well for one thing disconnected
operations don't really work very well
and there are some semantic meanings to
AB
issues to which you have to keep in mind
when you decide whether something has to
be dynamically loaded or not that that
that becomes a real problem as well to
come up with so sorry about having all
these pictures and not being able to
explain it but the big concept of this
slide was really that you know that the
sort of the secret sauce if as you might
call it is this profiler and the
decision engine logic which decides
whether to offload something or not and
what the profiler does it it takes
running it takes some values from things
that are happening you know constantly
for example what is the execution time
what is the call graph look like how
many CPU cycles it takes some modeling
of the energy as input as well and it
also takes things like network latency
bandwidth optimization and network types
that you're operating on and it sort of
takes all this data creates an ILP out
of it builds and optimization functions
optimize decides based on that
optimization function whether it needs
to manage the system needs to execute on
the device or move it out and comes up
with an answer and so the performance
looks pretty damn good this is actually
real systems that we have built and they
work so for example this was a face
recognition system these are so these is
the legend is when you have a smartphone
with just a regular 3g connection here
is a smartphone with a Wi-Fi connection
with different latencies depending on
you know where the Maui no it'sit's and
you can see quite clearly that the
execution time for identifying face is
quite substantially different for with
low latency this is an example of energy
and it shows here you will see this
craft which is with Wi-Fi shows to be
higher energy the Maui system actually
you know did not generate this craft we
had to force it because this was a this
was a case where offloading did not make
sense over Wi-Fi okay I just want to
sort of demonstrate that but but here
are some of the data for example when
you playing games you can go from six to
13 frames per second and save a lot of
energy so I'm done really quickly so so
you know if you sort of look ahead about
and to think about the concept that I
talked about in cloudlets and all and
you say well their improvements in
network
you could argue that's true if you have
improvements networking but they would
still be less than for example what a
wireless LAN can give you okay so you
might get you know really really fast
settle networks but you know wireless
LANs are going it your multi gigabits
even today what about hardware in
storage that's true improvements are
there but you will never catch up to
what the cloud is going to be able to
provide you as well and similarly
cognitive reasoning and all that stuff
you're always on the right side a little
current or wrong side of the curve in
some sense whichever way you look at it
so so so the cloudlets thing I think
makes a lot of sense so I guess this is
my final slide that talks about having
the ability to sort of think about all
these services that in the cloud provide
the composition framework to be able to
use them and then also in certain cases
offload the engine to be able to receive
that if you want to sort of know a
little bit more here's the website and
if you want to think about teaching
courses and Hawaii please write to me or
Judith and that will gladly sort of work
with you to make that happen and sorry
for being fast